one of the chapters is about um
resilience and dealing with setbacks
you've had a bunch of setbacks in your
career with like injuries and and things
like that and I know that you know
anyone listening to this or watching
this will have also
experienced major or minor setbacks in
their life where they've maybe had a
goal or a vision or a purpose to work
towards and then the universe has
dropped a piano on them and like
something is something bad has
happened in I guess in your world you
know the the world of of of elite high
performance what are some strategies
that and your team have found helpful
for dealing with dealing with setbacks
yeah it's it's hugely important
particularly in in today's you know
today's world you need to understand we
don't live in a a a perfect world
there's going to be disappointments
there's going to be setbacks you're not
going to achieve every single goal you
set out to achieve but having the right
tools to to deal with those situations
can be a huge Advantage give you so much
motivation give you real strength and
desire to um to learn from those learn
from those moments so a lot of people
look at my career and just focused on
the success but I firmly believe the
person that I am today is not because of
the trophies that I've won or the the
accolades that I get it's it's because
of the the difficult times the
setbacks that I've had and that you know
the things that not many people sort of
know or or learn about and that's what I
you wanted to to share in the chapter in
my book around resilience and having the
right tools to deal with resilience so
there's
amazing um you know story that that I
tell that I used to hate to talk about
because it was at the 2011 Rugby World
Cup where we went on to win it um and
I'd been the vice captain of the team
for three years behind the great Richie
mcco but I'd never kep in the All Blacks
um whenever he wouldn't play I wouldn't
play for whatever reason but in the last
round robin game of the Rugby World Cup
in New Zealand I got the phone call the
day before the game The Last Round Robin
game to Captain the old blacks one of
the best uh phone calls that that I've
had and of course I said yes Richie mcco
pulled out late with a little niggling
injury and here I was really proud
moment uh to to Captain the All Blacks
for the first time so I went off to the
the press conference day before the game
uh to talk to the media about how proud
I was to finally Captain the All Blacks
what a special moment it was for my
family and I went off to our final
training run uh which is called the
captain's run which as the captain gets
to decide what you do this is quite a
proud moment this is feeling good it's
been a great day for me uh we went
through the captain's run I always
finished the captain's run with a few
shots at goal um and I've been kicking
goals ever since I could walk dad taught
me to kick with both feet as Ser as I
could walks I've kicked millions of
kicks in my life my last shot at go I
was lining up the kick and as I came in
Kick and the impact of the my boot
hitting the ball I dropped to the ground
and I had a serious injury and my groin
had just um had actually torn off my
pubic bone and I just fell to the ground
in extreme Agony and this is my third
world cup and I'd had two fa World Cups
we done so much work around the
psychology we I just felt like we were
destined to finally win a World Cup I
was 28 I was in the prime of my career
everything was going so well I thought
this is my time this is my moment and
and then for it to all be taken away by
such a serious injury I was I was
devastated so I rushed off to
the uh the the Medical Center where I
had scans so I was with my my doctor and
and then the specialist my doctor like
do you want to see the results and I was
like no I knew in my mind that my dream
was over this is and I'm a firm believer
that things happen for a reason but this
was going to be my last World Cup and
all those thoughts of why me why now why
such a serious injury nothing made sense
in my mind at all everything had just
been taken away from me I jumped in the
car to go back to the
hotel um and halfway on the Journey Back
to the Hotel I hey Doc you know is my
world cup dream over and she's like yes
and I just burst into tears I cried all
the way back to the hotel
went to my room you know players would
come through coaches would come through
to but they couldn't say anything
there's nothing that they could say
could change this and it was just like
dead silence every time uh someone came
in yeah it was it was nice to know that
they were thinking of me and make the
effort to come and and that helped but I
was distraught so I was I was angry I
was sad I was you know disappointed at
all the emotions you know running
through my
body and um
but then you know after a couple of days
I was like well hold on like you know
what does an all black great do in
situations like this so my purpose
really helped me through uh through this
this setback what does nor black great
do that's right nor black great rehabs
this injury better than anyone's rehab
this injury before and all that great um
resets goals you know you said that and
all that great needs to play for 10
years or longer so I signed a new
contract to play for another four years
in New Zealand
um to get me through to another world
cup um and also all black great puts the
team first so what does the team need me
to do now well I'm injured so I need to
help the player play in my position he
went on to get injured as well so they
brought in another player so I had to
help him he got injured he went to a
four string number 10 and it's a great
story because um the four string number
10 went on to kick the winning goal in
the World Cup final
but through that process
there was some great tools and learnings
to help me deal with resilience the
first one was the importance to to
grieve so far too often I see people
have a really setback disappointment and
they just they move on really positive
God it's not that important not it's not
that important actually right no no
really positive mindset straight away
and I've seen that it you know bites
them in the ass further down the track
CU they don't deal with your emotions
straight away so it's important to
grieve deal with your emotions so much
so that when I have an injury my wife
knows to stay away from me for 24 hours
I'm not a nice person to be around I'm
grumpy I'm angry I'm just dealing
processing it all but there needs to be
you need to flick the switch at some
stage so for me it was 24 hours and with
depending on the the severity of the
sitb back it can be a little bit longer
there's no point me moping around the
hotel room for the next 2 weeks feeling
sorry for myself so I do that for 24
hours I flick the switch that's when I
change my mindset into a positive one
okay what are the the goals that I want
to to set now that I've injured whether
it's your rehab or longer term of uh in
four years time so I reset my goals
that's another really important thing of
of dealing dealing with a
setback um so it's that's really helped
me and I had this new motivation to to
bounce back uh from from the inury yeah
uh 2012 I got named 12 months later you
know World rugby player of the year so I
I returned and had a fantastic year 2015
Rugby World Cup it's one of my sort of
best uh Rugby World Cups that I ever
played you know sort of Man Of Thee
match performance Rugby World Cup
finally I was able to bounce back all of
a
sudden four years earlier
when things weren't making any sense
they all made sense now um all those
moments and setbacks were built up to to
make me a stronger more motivated um
player and in 2015 so I kind of sit
across from you today knowing that uh
you know the person that I am today a
lot more sort of resilient and have the
tools to help deal with with resilience
is is uh because of of those setbacks
that that I had through my career hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye